ça fait des années que raymond levasseur
n'avait pas fait de ballades en forêt
avec ses deux genoux ravagé par
l'arthrose levé terrain des forces
armées peut normalement à peine marcher
mais là il emprunte des sentiers
accidentés et se penche pour prendre son
chien ouais je crois pas de tomber je me
sens en sécurité ici mais l'état des
murs sont passés par normalement masquer
la prothèse que monsieur levasseur met à
l'essai et andernos colette qui amplifie
la force de ses jambes
c'est plus que ma qualité de vie
l'appareil est développé par stéphane
bédard grand patron de l'entreprise b
temia situé à québec
donc c'est ici que nous assemblons du
débat la fed wazir l'ensemble de
l'appareil c'est un appareil qui
rencontre entièrement conçu tchèque avec
nous et de az en fait où est on prêt été
inventée guyzagn développer aussi c'est
un appareil bio mechatronics et de la
bio robotique starbucks est un appareil
robotisée avec des moteurs des censeurs
logiciel d'intelligence artificielle
l'ordinateur de l'appareil anticipe les
mouvements de la personne l'ordinateur
prend ces données là les analyses et
arrive à faire bouger une structure
mécanique à l'extérieur des gens qui
vont fournir une énergie additionnelle
aux jambes
l'appareil à d'abord été conçu pour
répondre à un besoin militaire le soldat
porte aujourd'hui plus de 100 à 150 lead
sur charles cros sur le dos alors les
armes aidé à travers le monde cherche
une solution à travers ce problème le
quai majeur parce qu'aujourd'hui
maintenant les soldats tombés au combat
à cause de cette surcharge de poids et
non à cause d'autres fatalité pour
l'instant le des remous squelette à une
autonomie d'environ six heures lorsqu'il
est utilisé de façon intense afin de
s'assurer que l'appareil puisse être
utilisé dans le cadre d'opérations b
temia teste actuellement la version
militaire avec différentes armées dans
le monde
non non non marseille ça se contrôle de
l'appareil
c'est pour la force plus que des ports
d'amendé comme monter en pente ou un
marché plus longtemps de ce monde à
force au maximum capable de braver la
version médicale peut de son côté
redonner une vie aux gens en perte
d'autonomie
ceux qui ont des pertes de mobilité au
cours de leur vie à cause principalement
de mettre dégénératives comme la
sclérose en plaques parkinson ou aussi
l'arthrose ou genou et à large
l'appareil évidemment permet d'arriver à
maintenir cette capacité de marché
pour raymond levasseur le port du dermau
squelette a également pour effet de
réduire ses douleurs aux genoux provoqué
par l'arthrose pose une question
êtes-vous de redonner un bon coup de
marteau sur le pouce
ces soldes le matin meubles la douleur
de ben arous et sur le délai de départ
s'est soulevé les genoux puis au fur et
mesure que la journée avance les
douleurs augmentent mais là après
plusieurs minutes de marche
la douleur reste stable à l'augmenter
quand je les ai toujours de tels
appareils la 3e journée
mon niveau du lord matin avait commencé
à diminuer parce que ce train c'était
beaucoup moins l'eau monsieur levasseur
ne fait actuellement que des essais avec
l'appareil mais tente désespérément d'en
obtenir un se trouver des fonds pour la
technologie de b temia coûte environ
40000 dollars
une dépense qui n'est toujours pas
remboursés par les assureurs
l'équipe de monsieur d'eads a reconduit
démontré que la technologie réduit les
coûts des soins relié à certaines
maladies dégénératives en redonnant une
plus grande mobilité aux gens en perte
d'autonomie
pour moi ça cesse c'est un miracle pour
mes soucis
le moteur vin ordinaire